These special episodes of 99% Invisible are brought to you by the Lexus GX and Sirius XM. The new Lexus GX shows how an off-roading, overlanding vehicle can also be a true luxury vehicle. Every GX comes standard with Sirius XM, offering a rich array of music, sports, talk, and news. Huge thanks to the Lexus GX and SiriusXM for making this episode possible. Later, we'll meet up with a special guest, SiriusXM host, Rich Davis, and experience the GX firsthand. So stay tuned. To learn more about the GX, visit lexus.com slash GX, and with every purchase, you'll get three months of SiriusXM free. The all-new Lexus GX. Live up to it.
99% Invisible 的这些特别节目由雷克萨斯 GX 和 Sirius XM 赞助播出。全新雷克萨斯 GX 展示了越野和长途探险车辆如何也能成为真正的豪华座驾。每一台 GX 都标配 Sirius XM，为您提供丰富多彩的音乐、体育、脱口秀和新闻节目。非常感谢雷克萨斯 GX 和 SiriusXM 让本期节目的制作成为可能。稍后，我们将与特邀嘉宾、SiriusXM 主持人里奇·戴维斯（Rich Davis）会面，并亲自体验 GX。所以请继续收听。要了解有关 GX 的更多信息，请访问 lexus.com 斜杠 GX，每次购买都将免费获得三个月的 Sirius XM 服务。全新雷克萨斯 GX。不负期待。
The all-new Lexus GX. Live up to it. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars in Santa Fe. This is the second episode in a three-part series of me recording on location guides to the design features and cool architecture in the cities I love. These bonus episodes are made possible by the new 2024 Lexus GX and Sirius XM who heard this idea and sent me on my merry way and then shipped a Lexus there and took pictures of me bottling next to it, which is not something I thought would ever happen to say the least. So over the past few years, we have fallen in love with the city of Santa Fe in Mexico. We, I mean, me and Joy. Hey Joy.
全新雷克萨斯 GX。不负期待。这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars），我在圣达菲。这是我三集系列节目的第二集，我将在我喜爱的城市进行实地录音，介绍设计特色和酷炫的建筑。这些特别节目由全新 2024 款雷克萨斯 GX 和 Sirius XM 倾情赞助，他们听说了这个想法，便让我开启了愉快的旅程，还在当地运来了一台雷克萨斯，拍下了我靠在它旁边瓶装水的照片——至少可以说，这是我从没想过会发生的事情。所以在过去的几年里，我们爱上了新墨西哥州的圣达菲这座城市。我们，指的是我和乔伊。嘿，乔伊。
Hi there. So we've been to Santa Fe many times together and we've learned about its history together. So a lot of this might be a little bit remedial and mansplaining, you know, but you know. What do you mean mansplaining? Well, I mean like, I'm not falling for that. Okay, so we are in Santa Fe Plaza in the historic district of this city. So could you describe the buildings for me? The buildings are short and earthen and brown and beautiful. I think they're amazing. That traditional style of adobe that's on display here looks the way it looks because of this high desert terrain. Early builders in the region didn't have much access
大家好。所以我们一起去过圣达菲很多次，我们一起了解了它的历史。所以这里的很多内容可能有点像补习和男式说教（mansplaining），你知道的，但是……你这话是什么意思，男式说教？我的意思是，呃，我可不会掉进这个陷阱里。好吧，我们在圣达菲广场（Santa Fe Plaza），也就是这座城市的历史街区。你能为我描述一下这里的建筑吗？这里的建筑低矮、土黄色、古朴而美丽。我觉得它们太棒了。这里展示的传统阿多比（adobe）风格之所以呈现出现在的样子，是因为这里的高原沙漠地形。该地区早期的建筑工人很难接触到
to tin or wood or rock. But what they had in great abundance was dirt and clay. And that's what's used to make adobe bricks. And then they're stuck on top of each other. And then they're stuck out with mud. One of my favorite lines ever uttered in the history of Nine Ims Unvisible was said by Sconofay resident Delaney Hall, who
锡、木材或岩石。但他们拥有极其丰富的泥土和粘土。这就是用来制作阿多比砖的材料。然后它们被堆叠在一起。然后用泥土抹在外面。《99% Invisible》历史上我最喜欢的一句台词是由圣达菲居民德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）说出的，
I'm taking most of this information from when she said, being in northern New Mexico will convince you that beige is a criminally underrated color. I totally agree. So everything about the look and feel of Santa Fe today stems from the fact that when they completed the Santa Fe Railroad in the late 1800s, even though it was called the Santa Fe Railroad, the tracks did not in fact pass directly through Santa Fe. So without being on the main rail line, Santa Fe just couldn't get any industry going and it was struggling economically and the population was rapidly shrinking. And so the mayor at
我大部分信息都借鉴自她的话。她说，来到新墨西哥州北部会让你确信，米色是一种被严重低估的颜色。我完全同意。因此，今天圣达菲的外观和感觉的一切都源于这样一个事实：当他们在 19 世纪末完成圣达菲铁路建设时，尽管它被称为圣达菲铁路，但实际上铁轨并没有直接穿过圣达菲。因此，由于没有在主要铁路线主干道上，圣达菲无法开展任何工业，经济陷入困境，人口迅速减少。于是当时的市长
the time put together a planning board and told them that they needed to come up with a plan to save the city. And they landed on tourism. So they aimed to be this authentic Southwest tourist destination. So the board wrote up a document that's become known as the 1912 plan. They recommended that the city preserve its traditional Adobe architecture, but the plan went even further than that. It said that any new development should also be done in what's called the Santa Fe style. They wanted to create a kind of city-wide architectural brand based on historical precedent.
组建了一个规划委员会，并告诉他们必须想出一个拯救城市的计划。他们将目标锁定在旅游业。因此，他们的目标是成为这个正宗的西南部旅游胜地。因此，董事会起草了一份后来被称为 1912 年计划的文件。他们建议该市保留其传统的阿多比建筑，但该计划远不止于此。它规定任何新的开发项目也必须以所谓的“圣达菲风格”进行。他们希望根据历史先例创建一种全市范围的建筑品牌。
And nothing like this had ever really been done before on this scale and it was pretty radical at the time. Like there's preservation of like Monticello and like old houses and things like this but this was like the idea of preserving the architectural style of the whole city and it was really kind of radical and interesting. So traditional adobe buildings were preserved like the palace of the governors which is right across the street from us. It dates back to 1610. And new traditional earthen construction was encouraged along with a new modern twist called the Santa Fe style, which doesn't always use actual bricks and mud. Like it said, it used reinforced concrete and steel to create the frame. And then they slapped some stucco and mud on top of it to make it look like a dopey and some people call that a faux dopey, which I think is funny.
在此之前，从来没有真正以这种规模做过类似的事情，在当时这相当激进。就像有蒙蒂塞洛（Monticello）以及老房子之类的保护一样，但这就像是保留整个城市建筑风格的想法，这真的非常激进且有趣。因此，传统的阿多比建筑得到了保护，就像总督府（Palace of the Governors）一样，它就在我们街对面。它的历史可以追溯到 1610 年。人们鼓励采用新的传统土木建筑，并结合了一种名为“圣达菲风格”的现代新风潮，这种风格并不总是使用真正的砖块和泥土。就像所说的那样，它使用钢筋混凝土和钢材来建造框架。然后他们在上面抹上一层灰泥和泥土，让它看起来像阿多比，有些人称之为“假阿多比”（faux dobe），我觉得这很有趣。
The architect John Gall meme is the person most associated with the Santa Fe style. He moved here in the 1920s because he had tuberculosis and he came here to recover and he fell in love with the architecture and he began perpetuating it with that sort of twist. There's a whole side story about how tuberculosis and coming out to New Mexico territory for curing tuberculosis is really the origin of the state and that's a whole like other story that someday John Green will tell us I think because he's right now looking about tuberculosis. And the thing about the 1912 plan is it really works. NFA really did thrive as a tourist destination for decades.
建筑师约翰·加尔米姆（John Gaw Meem）是与圣达菲风格联系最紧密的人。他在 20 世纪 20 年代搬到这里，因为他患有结核病，他来这里疗养，并爱上了这里的建筑，开始用这种风格发扬光大。还有一个旁敲侧击的故事，关于结核病以及来到新墨西哥领地治疗结核病如何真正成为这个州的起源，这完全是另一个故事，我想总有一天约翰·格林（John Green）会给我们讲述，因为他现在正在研究结核病。关于 1912 年计划的一点是，它确实管用了。几十年里，圣达菲确实作为旅游胜地繁荣发展起来。
But modernism and more and more modern buildings were beginning to encroach. They were selling the traditional style that the tourism boosters were trying to preserve. And so in 1957, the city leaders took that 1912 plan and they doubled down like the city passed an ordinance that required the Santa Fe style in historic areas. It elaborated a number of sub-styles, a design board was created that had to approve all the aesthetics of any new construction or remodeling, and they created this large historic district in the center of the city,
但现代主义和越来越多的现代建筑开始侵入。他们一直在出售旅游推崇者试图保护的传统风格。因此，在 1957 年，城市领导人拿出了 1912 年的计划并加倍投入——该市通过了一项条例，在历史街区强制推行圣达菲风格。它详细阐述了许多子风格，成立了一个设计委员会，必须批准任何新建筑或改建的美学，他们在城市中心创建了这个大型历史街区，
which is where we're standing now. So over the decades, this created some seismic knock-on effects around density and gentrification, and all that was described really, really well in the story that Delaney Hall did, called Stuck Out in Time. And so this is just the short version,
也就是我们现在站的地方。几十年来，这在密度和士绅化方面产生了一些连锁反应，德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）名为《凝固在时间中》（Stuck Out in Time）的报道中非常非常出色地描述了这一切。所以这只是简短的版本，
but it's the foundation of kind of everything we're gonna see today. So I kind of had to like go through it again because you have to understand that that's what was happening The key takeaway from all this and the reason why all this looks the way it does is because over 150 years ago Someone decided that the Santa Fe railroad shouldn't stop in Santa Fe I mean eventually like a spur came out about 18 miles away from the main line But the damage was already done. If it's not on the main line,
但它算是我们今天将要看到的一切的基础。所以我不得不再次经历它，因为你必须明白这就是当时发生的事情。这一切的关键所在以及所有这一切看起来如此的原因是，在 150 多年前，有人决定圣达菲铁路不应该在圣达菲停靠。我的意思是，最终一条支线延伸到了距离主线大约 18 英里远的地方，但伤害已经造成了。如果不在主线上，
it just, it really is kind of on its own. So I think that this like very slippery idea of authenticity is the key to understanding this place. Like, and I say that without judgment. It's not that like authentic is good and inauthentic is necessarily bad. I don't even know what those things mean anyway when it comes to things like architecture and design.
它真的就像是孤立无援。所以我认为“真实性”这个非常微妙的概念是理解这个地方的关键。而且我说这话时并没有带任何评判色彩。并不是说真实的就是好的，不真实的就是绝对坏的。当涉及到建筑和设计之类的事情时，我甚至不知道这些东西到底意味着什么。
But it's something that I always have in mind here and it's something to really think about when you think about all the stuff that's around. So we should cross that way over the plaza to the Five and Dime General Store on the corner of the plaza. And it brings us to the subject of Frito pie. So can you describe Frito pie?
但这是我在这里时一直铭记在心的事，也是当你思考周围所有这些东西时真正需要去思考的事。所以我们应该穿过广场，走到广场拐角处的“五毛美分”（Five and Dime）杂货店。这就把我们带到了“玉米片派”（Frito pie）的主题。那么你能描述一下玉米片派吗？
Yes, I love Frito pie. You have Frito chips and it's topped with some chili and some diced raw onions and you eat it with a spoon and you eat it directly out of the bag. The thing to keep in mind for people who've never heard of Frito Pie, it is not a pie. It's a pile of chips and chili and cheese and onions and sometimes sour cream or you know something like that. But the great innovation when I think it's pretty cool is that it's served inside of a bag of Fritos. You know, it's pretty cool. Yeah. The reason we're talking about FritoPie is that you'll find FritoPie on a lot of menus
是的，我喜欢玉米片派。你有玉米片（Frito chips），上面浇上一些辣椒酱和切碎的生洋葱，你用勺子吃，直接从袋子里吃。对于那些从未听说过玉米片派的人来说，需要记住的一点是，它不是派。它是一堆玉米片、辣椒酱、奶酪和洋葱，有时还有酸奶油，或者你知道的那类东西。但伟大的创新——我认为它相当酷——是它是装在一个 Fritos 玉米片袋子里端上来的。你知道，这挺酷的。是的。我们谈论玉米片派的原因是，你会在圣达菲各地的很多菜单上找到玉米片派，
around Santa Fe, but according to some, FritoPie was invented in this location, the Five and Time, by a woman named Teresa Hernandez who worked at the lunch counter here when it was a Woolworth's in the 1960s. So it is no longer a Woolworth's, but they do still manage to have at the lunch counter here when it was a Woolworth's in the 1960s. So it is no longer a Woolworth's, but they do still manage to have a small lunch counter which in and of itself seems like a miracle and they still serve Frito Pie. Now this history of the Frito Pie does not comport with the official history from the Frito Lay Company of Texas. And they say that Daisy Dean Doolin,
但据某些人说，玉米片派是 20 世纪 60 年代这里曾是一家伍尔沃斯（Woolworth's）百货公司时，在午餐柜台工作的一位名叫特蕾莎·埃尔南德斯（Teresa Hernandez）的女性在这个地方——“五毛美分”发明的。所以它不再是伍尔沃斯了，但他们确实设法在这里保留了一个小型午餐柜台，这本身看起来就像个奇迹，而且他们仍然供应玉米片派。现在，玉米片派的这段历史与德克萨斯州菲多利（Frito-Lay）公司的官方历史并不相符。他们说黛西·迪恩·杜林（Daisy Dean Doolin），
the original fryer of Fritos, like the inventor of Fritos, and the mother of Elmer Doolin, the founder of Frito-Lay, is the true inventor of Frito-Pi. Like she's the first person to put chili on top of Fritos and add cheese and onions and stuff and eat it with a spoon. But I do think that Teresa Hernandez
Fritos 的最初油炸制作者，也就是 Fritos 的发明者，同时也是 Frito-Lay 创始人埃尔默·杜林（Elmer Doolin）的母亲，才是玉米片派真正的发明者。就像她是第一个在 Fritos 上面放辣椒酱并加入奶酪和洋葱之类的东西，然后用勺子吃的人。但我确实认为特蕾莎·埃尔南德斯
has given credit for eating it out of the bag, which I think is like a real leap forward. For sure! But if you order Frito Pie some other places, it might not be in the bag. Just just just be warned, okay? So the reason I'm bringing all this up is because there are all these kind of food feuds and fuzzy food origin stories in the world. Like there's two cities and like Pennsylvania and Ohio respectively who fight over who invented the banana split, one in 1904 and one in 1907. And there's this contested origins of who made the first like mission burrito in San Francisco, though you know the big one with the with all the rice and
因从袋子里吃而受到赞誉，我认为这是一个真正的飞跃。当然！但如果你在其他地方点玉米片派，它可能不在袋子里。只是，只是，只是请注意，好吗？我提起这一切的原因是世界上所有这些关于食物的争端和模糊的食物起源故事。就像宾夕法尼亚州和俄亥俄州分别有两个城市争夺谁发明了香蕉船，一个在 1904 年，一个在 1907 年。还有关于谁在旧金山制作了第一个类似“教会区卷饼”（mission burrito）的争论——你知道那种里面有所有米饭和
stuff in it and the big mission burrito. And it's kind of like all these people in the Midwest who fight over who has the largest ball of twine, you know? And just like that example, it doesn't actually matter who's right, in my opinion. It's the fight that matters. It doesn't behoove anyone to have this matter settled, especially the people at the Santa Fe Plaza of Ivan Dime. Like it doesn't matter which is the most authentic
各种配料的大型教会区卷饼。这就有点像中西部所有那些争论谁拥有最大麻球的人，你知道吗？就像那个例子一样，在我看来，谁是对的其实并不重要。重要的是争论本身。把这件事解决对任何人都没有好处，尤其是圣达菲广场“五毛美分”店的人们。最正宗的
or the most real. What matters is that the fight kind of stokes your passion and you form an intractable opinion about its true origin and the authentic way to eat it. Like for example, that it should be eaten only out of a bag of Fritos with his rune. Yeah. And you come to the five and dime or any other place and you express that preference with your dollars. That's really what matters. You know, I think the fight is what matters. So I don't really care who did it first.
还是最真实的，这并不重要。重要的是这种争论激起了你的热情，让你对其真正的起源和正宗的吃法形成了根深蒂固的看法。比如，它应该只用勺子从 Fritos 袋子里吃。是的。然后你来到“五毛美分”或其他任何地方，用你的金钱表达这种偏好。这才是真正重要的。你知道，我认为争论才是最重要的。所以我真的不在乎是谁第一个做的。
I don't either. I just like that it's good. And I find a way that I find the most satisfying way to eat it. So much so that when we got married, you want to tell them that we had as our late night snack when we got married? Sure. We had to have Frito Pie. We had to have Frito Pie because it's the greatest snack.
我也不在乎。我只喜欢它很好吃。而且我找到了我认为最令人满意的吃法。以至于当我们结婚时，你想告诉他们我们结婚时的深夜小吃是什么吗？当然。我们必须吃玉米片派。我们必须吃玉米片派，因为它是有史以来最棒的小吃。
And it was a great late night snack after everyone's dancing. You pass around bags of chips and it has chili on top of it. It's awesome. It made me so happy. Yeah, so good. Okay. So we'll get some couple bags of Frito Pie later. But let's go back across the plaza to basically where we were before to talk about an architectural feature that is super interesting to me
而且在大家跳完舞后，它是一份很棒的深夜小吃。大家传着一袋袋玉米片，上面有辣椒酱。太棒了。这让我太开心了。是的，太棒了。好吧。所以我们稍后会去买几袋玉米片派。但让我们穿回广场，基本上回到我们之前的地方，来谈谈一个对我也超级有吸引力的建筑特色。
So if you look at the Palace of the Governors, you'll see these tree trunks sticking out of the walls near the ceiling and those are Vicas and they are part of traditional adobe architecture and they hold up the roof and they attach the roof to the exterior walls. And just like other aspects of the Santa Fe style, this was an essential and sort of structural thing in the building of these of adobe, but they became kind of ornamental. This old building, it's mostly structural and then and when they did some remodeling, that actually they had ornamental vigas. So newer buildings will have vigas
所以如果你看总督府，你会看到这些树干从天花板附近的墙壁上突出来，这些就是“维加斯”（vigas），它们是传统阿多比建筑的一部分，它们支撑着屋顶，并将屋顶固定在外墙上。就像圣达菲风格的其他方面一样，这是建造阿多比建筑时必不可少的结构性东西，但它们后来变得有点像装饰品。这座老建筑，它主要是结构性的，然后当他们做一些改动时，实际上它们有了装饰性的维加斯。所以更新的建筑会有
that are just there to look cool and to give sort of an authentic feel, like Adobe feel. And those sort of mid-century building codes that we were talking about, they're about preserving and perpetuating the Santa Fe style. They gave you like high marks if you have, you know, like ornamental vigas projecting from your building, whether or not they serve any purpose of them to just look like the Santa Fe style.
纯粹为了好看而存在的维加斯，赋予一种正宗的感觉，比如阿多比的感觉。我们之前讨论过的那些世纪中叶的建筑规范，它们是为了保护和发扬圣达菲风格。如果你有——你知道的——从建筑物中突出的装饰性维加斯，无论它们是否起到任何模仿圣达菲风格的作用，都会为你带来高分。
Okay, so the interesting thing about these original structural vigas is that, you know, they're real wood beams made out of a single tree trunk and because of wood characteristics and availability and transportation, vigas mostly max out at about 15 feet long. And so because of that limitation, buildings built for a long time in the traditional way could only have interior rooms that were less than 15 feet wide.
好吧，关于这些最初的结构性维加斯，有趣的一点是，你知道，它们是由单一树干制成的真实木梁，由于木材的特性、可用性和运输，维加斯通常长度上限约为 15 英尺。正因为这种限制，长期以来以传统方式建造的建筑物，其内部房间的宽度只能小于 15 英尺。
And I think that maybe you felt that, like we've been in a lot of these traditional buildings down here and everything's really small. Yeah, yeah. Even if you build a little taller, like a mission church or something like that, that central room, you know, that whatever you call it, like, where you pray, you know, the pews and stuff.
我想也许你感受到了这一点，就像我们去过这里很多这些传统的建筑物一样，里面一切都真的很小。是的，是的。即使你建造得更高一点，比如传教教堂或类似的东西，那个中央房间，你知道的，无论你管它叫什么，就像，你祈祷的地方，长椅之类的。
Uh-huh. Yeah. I'm not very familiar. I don't go to church. But, but, all, even those are not all that wide. They're tall, but they're not all that wide. And we've been to some of the mission churches here, and they're, again, pretty narrow. And I think that sort of that size limitation that the Vigas sort of necessitated meant that you can you kind of can fall in love like the scale of it feels like human scale you know and
嗯哼。是的。我不太熟悉。我不去教堂。但是，但是，所有这些甚至都没有那么宽。它们很高，但没有那么宽。我们去过这里的一些传教教堂，它们同样非常狭窄。我认为维加斯所必需的那种尺寸限制意味着你可以爱上它，它的尺度感觉就像是人类的尺度，你知道的，
it's meant to be interacted with in that way and you can just really put your arms around this place. So one of the people who really put his arms around this place was J. Robert Abenheimer, the father of the atomic bomb. So here's a little segue for you. So when he was young, he said, my two great loves are physics and New Mexico. It's a pity they can't be combined. And when he was put in charge of the Manhattan Project, he finally got to combine them.
并且它旨在以那种方式进行互动，你真的可以双臂环抱这个地方。因此，真正双臂环抱这个地方的人之一就是罗伯特·奥本海默（J. Robert Oppenheimer），原子弹之父。所以这里有个小过渡。当他年轻时，他说，我的两大挚爱是物理学和新墨西哥州。遗憾的是它们无法结合。当他被委任领导曼哈顿计划时，他终于将它们结合在了一起。
Like he loved to camp and ride horses in the New Mexico High Desert. So when the government needed to build a secret town to house all the scientists of the project, he suggested Los Alamos as their secret base of operations. So the problem is, if you're trying to get all these scientists and engineers and technicians to a top secret town in the desert, you can't just give them an address and tell them to show up. Like that we wouldn't be a secret town for very long. So instead he told the people that they recruited to go to 109 East Palace. It's about half a block from the plaza and we should go there now and into the little courtyard.
就像他喜欢在新墨西哥州的高原沙漠中露营和骑马一样。因此，当政府需要建立一个秘密小镇来安置该项目的所有科学家时，他建议将洛斯阿拉莫斯（Los Alamos）作为他们的秘密行动基地。问题是，如果你试图将所有这些科学家、工程师和技术人员带到沙漠中的一个绝密小镇，你不能只给他们一个地址让他们出现。那样的话，我们的小镇就做不了多久的秘密了。相反，他告诉他们招募去 109 东宫街（109 East Palace）的人。它离广场大约半个街区，我们现在应该去那里，走进小庭院。
The primary contact person who greeted arrivals at 109 East Palace was Dorothy Scarrett McKippen and she would arrange transport for these scientists to go from here to the secret facilities and there's this plaque that commemorates all this in the back of the courtyard and it reads 109 East Palace Santa Fe office Los Alamos Scientific Laboratory, University of California. All the men and women who made the first atomic bomb passed through this portal to their secret mission at Los Alamos. Their creation in 27 months of the weapons that ended World War II was one of the greatest scientific achievements of all time. The dates are 1943 to 1963.
在 109 东宫街迎接到达者的主要联系人是多萝西·斯卡雷特·麦基彭（Dorothy Scarritt McKibben），她会安排这些科学家从这里前往秘密设施，庭院后面有一块牌匾纪念这一切，上面写着：109 东宫街，圣达菲办公室，洛斯阿拉莫斯科学实验室，加利福尼亚大学。所有制造了第一颗原子弹的男人和女人都穿过这座门廊，前往他们在洛斯阿拉莫斯的秘密使命。他们在 27 个月内创造了结束第二次世界大战的武器，是历史上最伟大的科学成就之一。日期是 1943 年至 1963 年。
That plaque is left over the coffee shop and... Casimir store, Casimir and chocolate. Casimir and chocolate shop. Has my name on it. It's called, it's called Oppies. It's named after Oppenheimer. So he has a connection to this place and they sort of keep some of that stuff alive. So let's leave the Plaza area and just go a few blocks away and meet up
那块牌匾留在咖啡馆上方，还有……卡西米尔店，卡西米尔和巧克力。卡西米尔和巧克力店。上面有我的名字。它叫，它叫奥比斯（Oppies）。它是以奥本海默的名字命名的。所以他和这个地方有联系，他们保留了其中的一些东西。让我们离开广场区，走到几个街区外，去见一下
with Delaney Hall. Okay, so we are here with our Santa Fe correspondent, Delaney Hall. Tell us about a very cool, very, very old Santa Fe thing. So tell me where we are. Okay, so we are standing here outside. It's chilly and kind of snowy. And we are next to something that you definitely wouldn't notice unless someone pointed it out to you. So it's a narrow ditch. It's like a few feet deep, a few feet wide, pretty modest. It's kind of lined with rock. But this is actually like a super important piece of infrastructure in Santa Fe. So it is the Asequia Madre, which is otherwise known as the Mother Ditch. And it has been here for at least 400 years since the earliest days of Santa Fe. And I brought you here because I think the history of this ditch will basically tell you something about the local culture of northern New Mexico
德兰尼·霍尔。好的，我们现在和我们的圣达菲通讯员德兰尼·霍尔在一起。给我们讲讲一个非常酷、非常非常古老的圣达菲事物吧。告诉我们我们在哪里。好的，我们正站在外面。天气很冷，还下着雪。我们旁边有一个东西，如果不是有人特意指给你看，你绝对不会注意到。所以它是一条窄窄的沟渠。它有几英尺深，几英尺宽，相当简陋。它有点用石头砌成。但这实际上是圣达菲非常重要的一项基础设施。这就是阿塞克亚马德雷（Asequia Madre），也就是通常所说的母亲沟（Mother Ditch）。它在这里已经至少 400 年了，可以追溯到圣达菲的最早时期。我把你带到这里是因为我认为这条沟渠的历史基本上会告诉你一些关于新墨西哥州北部的地方文化，
and also just how important water is in a place as dry as this. Okay, so tell me more about that history. Okay, so the Asakia Monterey, it was dug out not long after Santa Fe was founded in 1610 and it was designed to carry water from the Santa Fe River to the homes and gardens of the early settlers in Santa Fe. So it provided water for crops and livestock. And then over hundreds of years, this neighborhood has become not so much a farming community. Instead, it's like a quite fancy neighborhood with lots of very expensive homes. But the ditch is still here. And amazingly, it has been in continuous operation. So this is a 400-year-old ditch, like still doing its thing.
以及水在这样一个干旱的地方是多么重要。好的，请告诉我更多关于那段历史的信息。好的，阿塞克亚马德雷（Asakia Monterey）是在 1610 年圣达菲建立后不久开挖的，旨在将水从圣达菲河输送到早期圣达菲定居者的家园和花园。它为农作物和牲畜提供水。数百年来，这个社区已经不再是一个农业社区。相反，它变成了一个相当高档的街区，有许多非常昂贵的房屋。但这条沟渠依然在这里。而且令人惊叹的是，它一直在持续运营。所以这是一条拥有 400 年历史的沟渠，依然在发挥着它的作用。
So is this ditch totally unique, or is this part of a system of ditches for irrigation? So this ditch is very unique in Santa Fe, and its history is unique, and its role here in town. But actually, like, all over northern New Mexico, can find Asakias like this one. So they're part of these branching systems of ditches that carry water from rivers out into the communities that surround them, and they have a pretty cool history. So the word Asecia actually comes from an Arabic term, which means water conduit, and this style of irrigation canal goes back to the ancient Arab world, where people were developing techniques to grow food in very dry
那么这条沟渠是完全独一无二的，还是它是灌溉沟渠系统的一部分？这条沟渠在圣达菲非常独特，它的历史、它在这里镇上的角色都是独一无二的。但实际上，整个新墨西哥州北部，你都可以找到像这样的阿塞克亚（Asakias）。所以它们是纵横交错的沟渠系统的一部分，将水从河流输送到周围的社区，它们有着非常酷的历史。所以 Asecia 这个词实际上源于一个阿拉伯语术语，意思是水渠，这种风格的灌溉运河可以追溯到古代阿拉伯世界，当时人们正在开发在非常干燥的地方种植作物的技术。
places. And then here in northern New Mexico, indigenous peoples developed similar irrigation techniques over the thousands of years they've lived here. And then when the Spanish colonized this area, they brought their own style of irrigation to which they had inherited from the Arab world. Is this part of ancient history, or is this still like, why is this ditch still here? Right, well, it is very old history, but it also is still in use. Like even this Aseke Amadre is still in use.
然后在这里的新墨西哥州北部，原住民在他们在这里生活的数千年里开发了类似的灌溉技术。当西班牙人殖民这个地区时，他们带来了他们从阿拉伯世界继承的自己风格的灌溉方式。这是古代历史的一部分，还是这仍然——为什么这条沟渠现在还在这里？对的，嗯，这是非常古老的历史，但它也仍在投入使用。甚至这个阿塞克亚马德雷（Aseke Amadre）也仍在投入使用。
It helped, you know, the people who live along here, at least some of them will have water rights and so every summer the ditch will carry water and you can have these little diversion channels which like pipe it on to your lawn So um, so that's sort of the use of the Ezequia Madre and Santa Fe like I said This is not so much a farming community anymore But all over northern New Mexico there still are small-scale farms and farming operations
它帮助——你知道的，住在这里的人，至少他们中的一些人拥有水权，所以每年夏天沟渠都会运水，你可以有这些小分水渠，把水引到你的草坪上。所以，嗯，这就是圣达菲 Aseke Amadre 的用途，就像我说的，这里不再是一个纯粹的农业社区了，但在整个新墨西哥州北部，仍然有小规模的农场和农业作业，
and even just local gardeners. And so you know I guess one of the things I find most fascinating about Asakias is that they are still very much an important part of the culture here and in fact they have shaped the culture here so so one really cool thing about them is that they basically have their own little systems of grassroots government that that have sprung up around them and the way it works is every Asecia has an Aakia association, which represents the interests of the people who live on the ditch and have water rights. And heading that association is Amir Domho, which is the water master, an amazing title,
甚至还有当地的园丁。所以，你知道，我想我对阿塞克亚最着迷的事情之一是，它们仍然是这里文化的重要组成部分，事实上它们塑造了这里的文化。所以关于它们一件真的很酷的事情是，它们基本上围绕着自己建立起了各自的小型基层政府系统，运作方式是：每个阿塞克亚都有一个阿塞克亚协会，代表住在沟渠旁、拥有水权的人们的利益。领导该协会的是阿米尔·多姆霍（Amir Domho），即水长（water master），这是一个了不起的头衔，
who oversees the distribution of water and the maintenance of the ditch. And what that really looks like, just as a small example, is that every spring, all the members of the Ezekia have to come together to clear out the weeds that have accumulated to make way for the water that comes in the summer. And so that means meeting your neighbors and working alongside all the people who are part of your watershed. It's just a very cool example of the collective management of water and the traditions and community that spring up around water here in the desert.
他负责监督水的分配和沟渠的维护。作为一个小例子，这实际上看起来像：每年春天，阿塞克亚的所有成员必须聚在一起清理积聚的杂草，为夏天到来的水流让路。这意味着要结识你的邻居，并与属于你流域的所有人并肩工作。这真的是一个很好的例子，展示了水的集体管理，以及在这里沙漠中围绕水涌现出的传统和社区。
Oh, that is so cool. I love the idea that they have like an adopt the highway system But it's about connected to watershed So you know like that because the real connection points the real like resource that you're dealing with is water Yeah, so like knowing like who's upstream of you is like so cool And you all have to come together to maintain that channel that brings the water to all of you It's really a neat system here. Well, that is so cool, Delaney.
哦，太酷了。我喜欢这个主意，他们就像有一个“认领高速公路”（adopt the highway）系统，但它是关于连接流域的。你知道，因为真正的连接点，你正在处理的真正的资源是水。是的，所以知道谁在你上游是多么酷的一件事。你们所有人都必须聚在一起维护那个为你们所有人带来水的渠道。这里真的是一个很棒的系统。嗯，这太酷了，德兰尼。
Thank you so much for bringing us here. That's awesome. Absolutely, you're welcome. We have one more stop a little bit out of town right after this break. This special bonus episode of 99% Invisible is brought to you by the 2024 Lexus GX and SiriusXM. The Lexus GX is at the apex of high end luxury
非常感谢你带我们来这里。这太棒了。绝对的，不客气。就在这个休息之后，我们还有最后一站，在离镇子稍微远一点的地方。99% Invisible 的这个特别精彩的番外节目由 2024 款雷克萨斯 GX 和 SiriusXM 赞助播出。雷克萨斯 GX 处于高端奢华
and high end utility. When we went to Santa Fe, Lexus let us play with the GX Luxury Plus, the very top of the line of the GX series. They also sent us the very top of the line senior advertising planner, Eric Kavanaugh, to walk me through all the features of this model, including my favorite one. This model has three rows of seating. And as anyone who travels with kids or travels with stuff knows that you pile in the kids, you pile in the stuff, the rear view mirror
和高端实用性的巅峰。当我们去圣达菲时，雷克萨斯让我们试驾了 GX 豪华Plus版（GX Luxury Plus），这是 GX 系列中最高端的顶配。他们还派出了最高级的高级广告策划师埃里克·卡瓦纳（Eric Kavanaugh）来带我了解这款车的所有功能，包括我最喜欢的功能。这款车型有三排座椅。正如任何与孩子旅行或带着行李旅行的人所知道的那样，当你把孩子塞进车里，把行李塞满时，后视镜
is pretty much non-functional at that point. But you have a solution for that. We do. It's the digital rear view mirror. So of course, you can have it in the analog mode, which is like the normal old mirror that you would expect. But just with just a flip of that switch, and now converts it to the digital rear view mirror. Which turns the rear view mirror into a high-def screen that is connected to a high-def camera
到那个时候基本上就没用了。但你有一个解决办法。我们确实有。这就是数字后视镜。所以当然，你可以将其置于模拟模式，就像你所期望的普通旧后视镜一样。但只需轻轻一拨开关，它现在就可以转换为数字后视镜。这会将后视镜变成一个高清屏幕，连接到一个高清摄像头上，
that is mounted to the outside of the rear window glass. That's going to give you an unobstructed view of your surroundings. As a person who drives around a bunch of kids with a bunch of stuff, I cannot tell you how useful that feature is to me. The 2024 Lexus GX Luxury Plus is perfectly suited to taking a bunch of people on the road where everyone can see in all directions, including the sky,
该摄像头安装在后车窗玻璃的外侧。这将为您提供周围环境畅通无阻的视野。作为一个开车载着一堆孩子和一堆东西的人，我无法告诉你这个功能对我有多大用处。2024 款雷克萨斯 GX 豪华Plus版非常适合带着一群人在路上行驶，每个人都可以朝各个方向看，包括天空，
because the massive panoramic roof and really experience the world in extreme comfort and style. That is the experience of being in the Lexus GX Luxury Plus. And when you're driving a bunch of people around who sometimes, you know, do not want to talk to me, even though I'm super interesting with fun facts and things and don't want to play road trip games and have very disparate musical tastes.
因为巨大的全景天窗让人以极其舒适和时尚的方式真正体验世界。这就是身处雷克萨斯 GX 豪华Plus版中的体验。当你载着一群有时——你知道的——不想和我说话的人时，尽管我是个充满有趣事实和事物、超级有趣且不想玩公路旅行游戏的人，而且他们有着截然不同的音乐品味。
I recommend turning on Sirius XM or one of the most charming people I've ever talked to, will entertain people with 20 years of pop music. I'm Rich Davis, I work at SiriusXM. I'm a host on Pop2K, The Pulse, and HitsOne. And so what made you gravitate towards pop music? You've been at SiriusXM for a long time. So like, why was this the area that you became centered on?
我建议打开 Sirius XM，或者由我交谈过的最迷人的人之一，用 20 年的流行音乐来娱乐大家。我是里奇·戴维斯（Rich Davis），我在 SiriusXM 工作。我是 Pop2K、The Pulse 和 HitsOne 的主持人。那么是什么吸引你走向流行音乐的呢？你在 SiriusXM 工作了很长时间。所以为什么这是你关注的领域？
Pop radio, I always just felt, was just so locked in. I know people are in rock and hip hop and country. I just feel like pop music, you're just sort of always in the loop. I enjoy mainstream stuff. Some people don't. I like living in the mainstream. So Pop2K is music from 2000 to 2009,
我一直觉得流行音乐电台总是那么合拍。我知道人们喜欢摇滚乐、嘻哈乐和乡村音乐。我只是觉得流行音乐，你总是处于潮流之中。我喜欢主流的东西。有些人不喜欢。我喜欢生活在主流中。所以 Pop2K 是从 2000 年到 2009 年的音乐，
which is current to me, but oldies to my children. But tell me what's going on with hits one What I love about hits one is I like hearing these new artists come up and I sort of I sort of take pride in knowing that Like Ed Sheeran was a brand new artist. I met him before he was not doing anything I remember Taylor Swift me being one of her first interviews when she went mainstream from country to pop I love seeing someone go from playing small little clubs to, holy crap, they're playing big venues now. I love to watch their, their hustle.
对我来说是当下的，但对我孩子们来说是老歌。但请告诉我 HitsOne 的情况。我喜欢 HitsOne 的地方在于我喜欢听到这些新艺术家崭露头角，我为自己知道这一点而感到自豪——就像埃德·希兰（Ed Sheeran）是一个崭新的艺术家时我就认识他，当时他还没什么名气。我记得泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）从乡村音乐转向流行音乐时，我是她的第一批采访者之一。我喜欢看到有人从在小型俱乐部演出，到“天哪，他们现在在大型场馆演出”。我喜欢看他们的拼搏精神。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And since you've been there doing it for a little while, you, you have that perspective. You've seen this happen over and over and over again. What kind of spark do they have that makes you think, oh, like this kid, I feel it that we're going to be talking about them in 20 years. It's hard to identify because there's some people that come in the room and kid, I feel it that we're going to be talking about them in 20 years. It's hard to identify because there's some people that come in the room and you're like,
对的。是的。是的。既然你在那里做了一段时间，你就有这种视角。你已经看到这种情况一遍又一遍地发生。他们身上有什么样的火花让你觉得，哦——就像这个孩子，我感觉到我们将在 20 年后还在谈论他们？这很难辨认，因为有些人走进房间，就像这个孩子，我感觉到我们将在 20 年后还在谈论他们？这很难辨认，因为有些人走进房间，你会觉得，
wow, charisma. This person's a star. One of the fun things about Serious XM is that you're talking about all walks of life in one place. I remember I was interviewing Henry Winkler, the Fonz. Yeah. And who walks by the studio, the glass window, Bruno Mars. And you see Bruno Mars saying, holy crap, it's Henry Winkler, the Fonz. I just sort of stepped back and I let them have a moment. And it was amazing. You can hear Rich Davis on Pop2k, the pulse and hits one. And you'll get all those channels and so much more with your free three month subscription
哇，有个人格魅力。这个人是个明星。Sirius XM 有趣的一点是，你可以在一个地方谈论各行各业。我记得我正在采访亨利·温克勒（Henry Winkler），也就是“方兹”（the Fonz）。是的。谁走过了工作室，玻璃窗旁，布鲁诺·马尔斯（Bruno Mars）。你看到布鲁诺·马尔斯说：“天哪，是亨利·温克勒，方兹。”我只是退后一步，让他们度过了一段属于他们的时刻。这太棒了。你可以在 Pop2k、The Pulse 和 HitsOne 上收听里奇·戴维斯的节目。购买新款雷克萨斯 GX，即可免费获得为期三个月的
to SiriusXM with the purchase of a new Lexus GX. To learn more about the GX visit lexus.com. The all new Lexus GX. Live up to it. So we are now 15 minute drive north of downtown in the foothills of the Sangra de Cristo Mountains at one of the trail heads of the Dale Ball trails. So, Dale Ball was a businessman who loved hiking. He came to Santa Fe kind of later in life and he noticed there was all this brilliant and beautiful
SiriusXM 订阅，您将获得所有这些频道以及更多内容。要了解有关 GX 的更多信息，请访问 lexus.com。全新雷克萨斯 GX。不负期待。所以我们现在距离市中心车程向北 15 分钟，位于克里斯托山脉（Sangre de Cristo Mountains）山麓的戴尔·鲍尔步道（Dale Ball trails）的其中一个步道起点。所以，戴尔·鲍尔是一位喜欢徒步旅行的商人。他在晚年的时候来到圣达菲，他注意到这里有所有这些灿烂而美丽的
landscape but people didn't have the right to hike it. It was this mess of public and private land and so he founded the Santa Fe Conservation Trust to negotiate easements with property owners and purchase land for conservation, work with the city and county to donate land, all of that to build a 25-mile looping network of public trails over 1150 acres that connect the national forest to Santa Fe proper. And this is the trailhead parking lot. In fact, one of the things that the city contributed is they paid for the parking lot. They built the parking lot for us to stand in and park, I guess. His whole mission was to make the trails accessible to everyone who wanted to be outside and join New Mexico. When you come here, there's nothing quite like it, right?
风景，但人们没有徒步的权利。这里是一团糟的公共和私人土地，因此他创立了圣达菲保护信托基金（Santa Fe Conservation Trust），与业主谈判地役权，购买土地进行保护，与市和县合作捐赠土地，所有这些都是为了在 1150 英亩的土地上建立一个 25 英里长的公共步道环形网络，将国家森林连接到圣达菲本部。这就是步道起点的停车场。事实上，市政府贡献的事情之一是他们支付了停车场的费用。他们给我们建造了供我们站立和停车的停车场，我猜是的。他的整个使命是让这些步道对每个想要去户外享受新墨西哥州的人开放。当你来到这里时，没有什么能与之相比，对吧？
No, there really isn't. You just want to be outside and looking at the sun. The color. Yeah. Yeah. It's unbelievable. And what's so great about these, the Dale Ball trails, is that they're really, they're close to town. They're easy to get to.
不，真的没有。你只想去户外看着太阳。那种颜色。是的。是的。这太不可思议了。这些戴尔·鲍尔步道最棒的地方在于它们离镇子很近。它们很容易到达。
They're open year round. There are some steep parts and amazing views, but a lot of it's really gentle. It's very inviting, I think. And you can feel this intention, trying to bring people in, especially in the trail design, which you remember, it totally blew us away the first time we were hiking here, right?
它们全年开放。有一些陡峭的部分和令人惊叹的风景，但大部分都非常平缓。我认为它非常引人入胜。你可以感受到这种意图，试图把人们吸引进来，特别是在步道设计中，你还记得，我们第一次在这里徒步时，它完全震撼了我们，对吧？
Yeah, it was remarkable. Yeah. And now we're seeing anything like it. They were well marked trails, didn't get lost, it all made sense. There was no question. Yeah. Which fork I should take. Totally.
是的，太了不起了。是的。现在我们看到了类似的东西。它们是标记清晰的步道，不会迷路，一切都说得通。没有任何疑问。是的。我该走哪条岔路。完全。
The signage is really clear and welcoming and it's a trail made for people who may be a little anxious about getting lost. That's right. There's a number given to each of the sort of crossroads and intersections and very clear directions to each. You know, we'd never seen anything like it. I was kind of amazed. In fact, it was the way finding and the trail design that made me want to look into the history of this place. Also, that it's called Dale Ball. You're like, why is it called Dale Ball? But you could tell there was a story behind the design, something very intentional. So the trail was designed by a retired US forestry manager named
标牌非常清晰和热情，这是一条为那些可能对迷路有点焦虑的人设计的步道。没错。每个十字路口和交叉路口都有一个编号，并且有非常清晰的指示。你知道，我们从未见过类似的东西。我有点惊讶。事实上，正是路线指引和步道设计让我想要了解这个地方的历史。还有，它叫戴尔·鲍尔。你会想，为什么它叫戴尔·鲍尔？但你可以看出设计背后有一个故事，非常有意图。所以这条步道是由一位名叫
Mike Wurz that Dale Ball convinced to come on board. And he, along with 50 volunteers, built these trails over five years until they were completed in 2005. An anonymous donor put up the money for all the trailblazing and the donor had two conditions for his donations. One was that he or she remained anonymous, that no one ever know who did it. And the other was that the trail is being named after Dale Ball. Yeah, it is a little suspicious. Okay. Um, but I do actually kind of believe it's an outside person. And the reason is because apparently through all this process for years
迈克·乌尔兹（Mike Wurz）的退休美国林业经理设计的，戴尔·鲍尔说服了他加入。他和 50 名志愿者一起花了五年时间建造了这些步道，直到 2005 年完工。一位匿名捐赠者为所有的开路工作提供了资金，这位捐赠者对他的捐赠有两个条件。一个是此人保持匿名，没有人知道是谁做的。另一个是步道以戴尔·鲍尔的名字命名。是的，这有点可疑。好吧。嗯，但我实际上有点相信这是一个外地人。原因是因为显然通过所有这些年的过程
and years of him working for the San Jose Conservation Trust, um, there were attempts to name other things after him and he refused. And so, but this one, apparently they acquiesced to because they really needed the money to complete it. And it's this lovely set of trails. Like I love it, we've hiked it before. It's snowing now, so it has this nice crunch when you walk onto it. You know, like it's a real gift
他为圣达菲保护信托基金工作，嗯，曾有人试图用他的名字来命名其他东西，但他拒绝了。所以，但这一个，显然他们默许了，因为他们真的需要钱来完成它。这是一套可爱的步道。我很喜欢，我们以前徒步过。现在在下雪，所以当你走上去时有一种很好的嘎吱声。你知道，就像这是一份真正的礼物，
that a person really cared about this place, gave this area. So Dale Ball died at the age of 91 in 2016. And so all this work that he did was all after he retired. He was in the 70s and 80s when he did all of this to build this place. So that just really tells me something. I think that's really amazing. So poor went out for Dale Ball in the Dale Ball trails. I love them. So that is our time in Santa Fe. This lovely place. It's the greatest. It is the greatest. Yeah, it's really, really lovely. I want to stay. Yeah, we could stay. Why don't we stay?
一个真正关心这个地方的人，把这个地方赠予了这里。所以戴尔·鲍尔于 2016 年以 91 岁的高龄去世。所以他做的所有这些工作都是在他退休之后。他是在 70 岁和 80 岁时做这一切来建造这个地方的。这真的告诉我一些事情。我觉得这真的太棒了。所以为戴尔·鲍尔和戴尔·鲍尔步道干一杯。我爱它们。这就是我们在圣达菲的时间。这个可爱的地方。这是最棒的。这是最棒的。是的，真的，真的很可爱。我想留下来。是的，我们可以留下来。我们为什么不留下来？
Dale Ball like showed up late in life and did all this stuff as if he grew up here. And I think that that I think that's a vibe. I think people show up here and and they and they go, oh, this is my place. Yeah, I mean, I've never seen anything like this. Or it's just different when you set foot in this city. Yeah. Hey, you want to walk a little bit? What do you want to walk a little bit? What do you want to walk? Maybe you could get into the trees.
戴尔·鲍尔就像是在晚年出现，做了所有这些事情，就好像他在这里长大一样。而且我认为——我认为这是一种氛围。人们来到这里，然后他们就会说，哦，这是我的地方。是的，我的意思是，我从来没有见过这样的东西。或者当你踏入这座城市时，感觉就是不同。是的。嘿，你想走一会儿吗？你想走一会儿吗？你想走什么路？也许你可以走进树林里。
Thanks for joining us for this special Santa Fe episode of 99% Invisible brought to you by the Lexus GX and Sirius XM. And thanks to Eric Kavanaugh, Rich Davis, and Joy Usan for being my special guests. The new Lexus GX showcases how aesthetic appeal complements utility. Proving luxury and capability can coexist. And when you throw a Sirius XM in there, you have everything you need to be out in the farthest reaches while still being connected to a passionate community of music-loving DJs, world-class talkers, comedians, and thinkers.
感谢收听本期由雷克萨斯 GX 和 Sirius XM 赞助的《99% Invisible》圣达菲特别节目。感谢埃里克·卡瓦纳、里奇·戴维斯和乔伊·乌森作为我的特别嘉宾。全新雷克萨斯 GX 展示了美学吸引力如何与实用性相辅相成，证明了豪华与性能可以共存。当你再加上 Sirius XM 时，你就拥有了在最偏远地区探险所需的一切，同时还能与热爱音乐的DJ、世界级谈话节目主持人、喜剧演员和思想家组成的充满热情的社群保持联系。
To learn more about the GX and Serious XM and Lexus vehicles, visit lexus.com. The all-new Lexus GX. Live slash GX. The all new Lexus GX. Live up to it. I also encourage you to go to this episodes page on 99pi.org where you can look at me posing with a very fancy car. And you can stream your first three months free of SiriusXM where you can listen
要了解有关 GX、Sirius XM 和雷克萨斯汽车的更多信息，请访问 lexus.com。全新雷克萨斯 GX。活出真我，驾驭无限。我还鼓励大家访问 99pi.org 上的本期节目页面，在那里你可以看到我与一辆非常豪华的汽车的合影。你还可以免费试用前三个月的 SiriusXM，收听
on the SiriusXM app online or on other compatible devices. You'll get more than 425 channels including ad free music plus sports, comedy, news, and more. You can listen anywhere on the all-new SiriusXM app. Go to 99pi.org to subscribe to SiriusXM. 99% invisible was reported this week by me, Roman Mars, and Delaney Hall, and edited by me, Roman Mars,
在 SiriusXM 应用程序上、在线或其他兼容设备上。你将获得 425 个以上的频道，包括无广告音乐以及体育、喜剧、新闻等。你可以在全新 SiriusXM 应用程序上的任何地方收听。访问 99pi.org 订阅 SiriusXM。本周的《99% Invisible》由我罗曼·马尔斯和德莱尼·霍尔报道，由我罗曼·马尔斯编辑，
with production help from Isabel Angel and Sarah Bake. Mix and sound design by Dara Hirsch, music by Swan Real. Kathy II is our executive producer, Delaney Hall is our senior editor, Kurt Colestead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason De Leon, Vivian Lay, Lausha Madon, Christopher Johnson, Martin Gonzalez, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Nina Pothock, Kelly Prime, and Jacob Muldonado-Madina. The 99% of his old logo was created by Stefan Lawrence, special thanks this week to the Randall Davy Audubon Center and Sanctuary. We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Vandora building. Our headquarters online is 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并得到了伊莎贝尔·安杰尔和萨拉·贝克的制作帮助。混音和声音设计由达拉·赫施负责，音乐由斯旺·里尔创作。凯西·II 是我们的执行制片人，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的资深编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、维维安·莱、劳莎·马登、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、马丁·冈萨雷斯、乔·罗森伯格、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、妮娜·波托克、凯利·普赖姆和雅各布·马尔多纳多·马迪纳。《99% Invisible》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作，本周特别感谢兰德尔·戴维奥杜邦中心和保护区。我们是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在北面六个街区的万多拉大楼。我们的在线总部是 99pi.org。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。